what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I originally didn't have any
video scheduled for Thursday and I was
like man I need video to come out today
like just the sake of having something
else and the more I started thinking
about it the more I was like well
Infinite Crisis like we're gonna be
getting into Infinite Crisis here in the
next couple of weeks or so and so I was
like I mean if that's going to be part
of our whole Green Lantern run and like
superboy-prime was like a huge card
event that a crisis is probably like the
best part of Infinite Crisis there why
not do the origin of superboy-prime the
problem was trying to find it like it's
the original origin of superboy-prime is
like it's like the most difficult thing
to find ever in the history of DC Comics
it's crazy
but we found it we have the origin of
superboy-prime the very first origin
written by Elliot s Magna now what we're
going to do with this is we're actually
that's going to kind of roll this into
our Green Lantern playlist we're gonna
kind of just throw it in there just
because of the fact that understanding
the origin of superboy-prime I really
think goes towards like what makes him
such an identifiable character what
makes them so interesting and infinite
crisis like why he's doing what he's
doing but this also kind of gives us a
little bit of a precursor it really kind
of ties in to crisis on Infinite Earths
the problem with this was that this was
really like an afterthought for Christ
on Infinite Earths so it kind of fits in
but it kind of doesn't it's really just
kind of shoehorn in there but because
we're not talking about crisis on
Infinite Earths we're talking about
infinite crisis we can just kind of take
the story as it is now there are a few
differences here from the traditional
Superman landscape and one thing that I
want to point out is what earth prime is
so in the realm of DC Comics and even in
the realm of Marvel Comics we have
what's basically the real world now
they're really the only two publishers
who do this and the reason why is
because Valiant Comics for example just
uses the real world I mean it's really
just kind of like our world for the most
part of the world outside your window
what would the world look like if X No
Man O'War we're running around right now
so that really kind of hits home with
like the the nature of their stories but
Marvel and DC focus on like the
superhero world what earth prime does
north pride has been around I think
since the 1950s what earth prime does is
it basically gives us the real world
incoming book form the first time I
really saw this I think it was the flash
I think was Barry Allen who crossover
into earth prime by accident but it was
really kind of an interesting thing but
in the realm of Earth Pond Superboy is
the only superhero that exists there
there are no other superheroes there's
no Green Lantern there's no flash no
Wonder Woman none of
superboy is the only one that hails from
earth prawn now in terms of the depth
I guess the designation superboy-prime
infinite crisis was the first time that
he referred to himself as superboy-prime
but in truth the name superboy-prime was
first used in this story so that's why
people sort of calling him
superboy-prime even before infinite
crisis absolutely because of the fact
that the name had already been given it
would already been established by Elliot
s magna now as we go to the story one of
the things we're going to find is how
the story is written here versus some
changes that geoff johns made in
Infinite Crisis and we'll talk about
those once we get to Infinite Crisis but
what this does is this basically picks
up with the destruction of Krypton it's
really a hallmark a classic story of the
Superman mythos it's the one thing that
doesn't change Krypton always ends up
being destroyed Superman always is up
being sent from Krypton over to earth
and that's really it but with regards to
earth Prime things are a little bit
different here for example when jor-el
approaches a science council and says
Krypton is doomed he's not considered a
quack he's not considered a crazy person
the science council says yes you're
right we have to do something about this
again you know Krypton Sun is basically
on the verge of going supernova and it's
on the verge of complete and total
destruction
eliminating Krypton in its entirety now
the problem with this is that the
science council is wanting to go the
route of like logic and reason or like
we have to form other councils to sort
this out and different things like that
but what jor-el is not telling them is
that their time is extremely limited
where they would form councils and they
would take weeks if not maybe a couple
months in order to figure out what steps
they need to take and then the time it
takes to implement those steps
jor-el's answer is where I guess really
his knowledge is that they have less
than a day and so they're basically
wrapping up insanely fast everything's
coming to a halt extremely quick now in
truth the reason why jor-el is doing
this is to buy time and the reason why
is because with him and his wife having
a child the goal is to basically find a
way to send their child away from
Krypton in order to keep their kid alive
but in order to make sure that no one
comes prying and asking questions only
really says is look you guys need to do
whatever is you need to do I mean we
have to find a solution to this problem
but at the same time like I'll be
working on a solution at home you know
what have you go get you guys go do your
own thing and so what we end up finding
out is that where the process of Krypton
Sun going supernova is affecting the
planet in different ways it's a gravity
kind of gravity waxes and wanes and
different things like that instead of
the traditional line
kal-el and this universe being sent from
Krypton on a ship instead it's actually
a teleportation device and that's what
jor-el does he basically approaches the
science council and says look you know I
have a device that will transfer that
will transport anything under 50 pounds
away to whatever location that we want
now what we have to do is basically
expand on this technology so that we can
teleport cities away but we can use this
to essentially save our lives you know
to keep our planet whole now of course
because the science council had been
dilly-dallying in the end this is just
really a ruse this is really just a way
for again jor-el to buy time so that his
wife can place their son I guess you
really kind of get the science council
out of there but he and his wife can
place you know kal-el in this
transportation devices teleportation
device and whisk it away now this is an
inherent difference between the
traditional Superman mythos and
superboy-prime
and the Superman mythos you had like
argo city right which basically survived
the entire experience survived the
entire ordeal and that's where Supergirl
comes from in the earth prime universe
no one survived a destruction of Krypton
it's gone it's completely history and in
addition to that something else to point
out is that in the regular Superman
mythos green kryptonite exists because
when you know Krypton was destroyed when
its core went radioactive I guess when
its core exploded that it ended up
leading to the planet literally just
exploding and then shards of kryptonite
flying throughout the universe some of
which eventually landed on earth because
of the fact that is eradicated by a red
Sun it's burned to a crisp there's
nothing left and so what this means is
there's no kryptonite in earth crime
that's one of the reasons why
superboy-prime is so wildly powerful in
Infinite Crisis is because there's no
kryptonite one of the things that they
establish there one of the things that
we'll cover again let's forget - that is
that kryptonite only works on the
universe or only works in a Superman
from that same universe so kryptonite
from earth one works on Superman from
Earth one Kryptonite from Earth two
works on Superman three earth 2 so on
and so on
kryptonite from Earth one will not work
on Superman from Earth two and so
because of this it basically means that
there's no counter to superboy-prime
there's no genuine way to defeat him
using traditional means to defeat
Superman which is why Geoff Johns
invoked the Green Lantern's and again
we'll get into that as well but kind of
rolling this into the Green Lantern
mythos is because all of this really
ties into like Green Lantern Corps and
then going into Sinestro Corps war and
all that comes stuff so what problem is
a huge part of that but here's a care
whose origin story and tales really kind
of predate anything Jeff John's did by
quite some time but the fact remains
here that he's basically discovered by
Mayo me and Jerry Kent which is actually
again a total change from what we're
used to but more so than that they end
up naming him Clark Kent but this is
when we basically learn or really it's
kind of reaffirmed the comic books exist
on earth pron remember this is basically
our world so when you're watching this
video you're watching the video on
superboy-prime what DC basically says is
that while you're on earth prime line
now watching this video there is a
universe where the events of this video
are happening you know there's a
universe where Infinite Crisis happen
there's a universe where superboy-prime
exists that's how it exists in this
story superboy-prime is used where prime
as me like Superman exists only in comic
book form and so because of that he
basically grows up without any powers
whatsoever he's just a normal person and
again that's a huge change here
traditionally a Superman growing up on
earth as Clark Kent was exposed to the
Yellow Sun his powers immerse at a very
young age and then from there it was
just going through his adolescence
learning to use his powers encountering
Lana Lang who in turn taught him how to
use his powers effectively taught him
would have meant to be a hero whereby he
eventually went on travel to Metropolis
met Lois Lane fell in love and the rest
is history and so because of that Clark
Kent I guess Clark Kent as he exists now
in terms of superboy-prime he maintains
his name
maintains his namesake of Clark Kent but
he has no powers he can be stabbed he
can be shot he can be punched really
hard and knocked out he runs at the
normal speed of a human being he's as
strong as a normal person anybody his
age he is for all intents and purposes a
regular person now from here this picks
up with the introduction of a girl named
Laurie and Laurie is essentially a
character just this chick that he's kind
of digging but the reason that reason is
so cool is because with with Clark Kent
growing up on earth cron and reading
comic books
Superman was his favorite character and
so they essentially dress up to go to a
you know a beach party a Halloween party
of sorts kind of hanging out and doing
their own thing but what this does is it
coincides with both his love for
Superman where he's dressed up as
Superman where he kind of acts out
fantasies about being Superman so on and
so forth but it also you know coincides
with the arrival of Halley's Comet now
under normal circumstances Halley's
Comet shows up I think like once every
75 years it's a cool thing to see and
nothing happens in DC Comics on earth
prime Halley's Comet puts off a
radiation of sorts and what it does is
it
of manifests in different ways it causes
you know all different kinds of weird
impacts and things like that but it also
impacts like the gravity of Earth and
things along those lines but what it
does is it essentially provide
superboy-prime
with powers now again this is 1985 so
we're not given these super in-depth
explanations on why things happen it's
just Halley's Comet passes by and now
superboy-prime has powers you know now
Clark Kent former front has superpowers
so what is up happening here is of
course you know with him having these
abilities you know he sees Halley's
Comet even though he shouldn't this is
what his you know telescopic vision
kicks in you know he goes to touch it
this is what he starts to fly and then
he encounters Superman now the reason
why this happens is because of the fact
that this takes place during the crisis
on Infinite Earths event and this is
really disappointing time one Superman
if I remember correctly was just
traveling around trying to find
reinforcements now the problem with this
is the continuity that it fits into in
the realm of DC Comics with crisis on
Infinite Earths the whole point of the
event was to basically eliminate the
multiverse and replace it with a
singular universe and that singular
universe existed between the end of
crisis on Infinite Earths to the end of
Infinite Crisis for that 20-year period
there was only ever one universe in DC
Comics the problem with this was that
the way the story progressed shortly
after the death of Supergirl it was
basically left to Superman of earth 1
and Superman of birth to two essentially
fight off anti-monitor along with all
the other heroes which more or less saw
his defeat until he reformed into the
singular universe the problem is that
where this story in terms of how the
story fits in it comes in after the
death of Supergirl which wouldn't make
any sense because there wouldn't be an
earth god there wouldn't be a multiverse
there would just be one universe and
that's the kind of continuity errors I'm
talking about that came out immediately
after crisis on Infinite Earths but for
the sake of the story we can just take
it at face value and just say you know
for whatever reason there is a there's
earth prime now and that's where
superboy-prime
comes from but the fact remains here
that within the confines of this story
superboy-prime is meeting his idol
remember for him Superman only ever
existed in comic books to suddenly
encounter him and to find out that he's
real is mind-boggling not only that
because of the effects of Haley's
comment you know because of all the
things that are going on there's a tidal
wave that's coming in and of course
Superman is Superboy prime were able to
basically stem this tidal wave whisk it
back into control use their heat vision
to more or less evaporate the water and
save the day and that's really it but at
this point it's really just super hard
hanging out
his idol now one of the things that
Elias Elliot s bagging establishes here
is that superboy-prime is stronger than
the standard Superman he is by all
standards of measurement stronger faster
more capable and so he's beyond the
regular Superman and that's one of the
reasons why when geoff johns brought
superboy-prime over into the Infinite
Crisis event that he was so unstoppable
that's why Sugoi prompt was able to take
on the Doom Patrol at Teen Titans the
Titans and a couple members of the
Justice Society of America all at the
same time because he's just such a
strong overpowered character like he
really needed to be nerfed it was wild
how Opie he was that's what people loved
him though because then let me taste
some that that fight man I'm so excited
I'm so excited to cover that fighter in
Infinite Crisis because he's just he's
whacking everyone I mean it's it's
hilarious because like like cassie
sandsmark like hey guys
I brought in like to do patrol and the
Justice Society is the Titans of stuff
this is where farms like man son you
better come strong it's one of the
coolest things is where the goddess on
to and boy I am so excited I'm I'm so
high I'm so high to do that story
because it's one of the coolest things
but again this is really just designed
to kind of give us an interaction
between the two now again of course
because of the fact that this was not
officially part of crisis on Infinite
Earths it was just kind of tied in you
know later on down the line what ended
up happening here is that you know it's
really just Elliot s mag and saying hey
look here's why Superman is here because
he crossed the dimensional barrier and
he wasn't able to find a way back home
and so because of this it's really just
kind of reason for why he's here but the
fact remains that in the middle of this
whole thing earth is basically what Lisa
seems like it's going to be invaded but
it's actually visited by you know really
this group called the arc the Arcturus I
think it is like I don't know I'm man
like this was 1980s comics guys like my
knowledge on this is scant at best when
it comes to DC but I'm pretty sure
that's where they where the archers or
tourists or something along those lines
but in the normal Superman universe ah
they're basically like tourists you know
in earth 1 they're basically tourists it
is going to show up in a visit earth and
like they just run off with some stuff
that seems weird to them and that's
really yet you know for them is kind of
investigating and poke around on earth
prime during a furious they're actually
bad guys they're pretty villainous the
reason being because of the fact that in
their mind everybody who was on Krypton
should have been destroyed but when they
when they show up on earth and they
realized that superboy-prime hails from
Krypton on earth pran that he's
basically somebody that's not supposed
to be there he's an anomaly
and so because of this their goal is to
essentially kidnap him and take him away
for them to just kind of keep and hold
on their own now of course Superman
comes to the rescue
and Superman is socially saves the day
but this is again another instance where
Elliot as Megan establishes that
superboy-prime does not have the same
sort of weaknesses that that Superman
does now this will be rectified by Geoff
Johns and the reason why is because what
Superman does is he tells superboy-prime
look these guys you know are here and
they're are cut they are kind of
nefarious we have to fight them off
because they're essentially going to try
to cause problems on earth more or less
but what Superman does is he leads
Superboy prong to their central core you
know where it is that all their power
hails from and of course Superman goes
on to explain that these guys basically
exist outside of the visual spectrum so
they seem invisible to anybody who can
who looks at them with the exception of
Superman to suit ward prime because they
have x-ray vision you know enhanced you
know vision abilities and so on and so
forth but with inside this bubble this
fear of energy is basically the power of
a red Sun Superman cannot damage this
bubble superboy-prime can punch right
through it and so what Elliot s magnet
is basically saying here is that
superboy-prime is not bound by the
limitations of a red Sun that even if
he's in the presence of a red Sun he can
fly and do all the same things that
Superman can do the problem with this is
that this takes away all conceivable
weaknesses of Superboy front kryptonite
doesn't exist so he can't be taken out
by kryptonite there's no red no blue no
yellow no green kryptonite of any kind
he's not impacted by a red Sun he's
stronger faster and more capable than
any other Superman that exists inside
the multiverse of DC Comics he has no
weaknesses and so if geoff johns where
she whirled him over into Infinite
Crisis with the same power scale that he
has now he would literally just destroy
everything like no one would be able to
stop him and so that's why geoff johns
more or less read calmness and through
in the red sun radiation as being a
weakness for Superboy drama so witness
ends up dealing is a basically this kind
of allows them to transport over to
earth one and then they just sort of
roll over into Infinite Crisis after
this I mean there's really not not a
whole lot of a whole lot of discussion
here pretty much wraps things up I mean
it goes into like Superman's own little
solo series you know but in terms of
superboy-prime
this is really just his origin this is
really where it all just
happens maybe Superman so on and so
forth but it's also establishing how
powerful he is in relation to everybody
else but if you guys are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys are
the sub button and become part of the
Rob port if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah
Infinite Crisis is right around the
corner I'm hyped I'm really excited
about Infinite Crisis it's such a good
story and it fits so well into the Green
Lantern Memphis remember after Infinite
Crisis we jump back into Green Lantern
with Green Lantern Corps that I think we
do like the origin of star sapphires and
then we get into like we start setting
the stage for the Sinestro Corps war but
again you know the first two arcs of
Jeff Jones green land Rose you guys
who've been asking because I've seen
comments on Twitter I've seen comments
in the comments section or really
questions in the comment section for
those are the guys who are asking the
question Geoff Johns Green Lantern and
you know includes Green Lantern Corps it
wasn't really written by him but it's
really kind of important to have real
Antron court but the first volume of
those no fear and Green Lantern Corps
recharge basically give us the state of
everything that's going on with the
Green Lantern mythos and then it just
kind of grows from there so just Geoff
Johns kind of building everything up but
yeah guys we're gonna go ahead and bring
this video to an end and I will catch
you all in it
[Music]